[Musique]
recevoir mes petits amis
nous voilà prêts eh oui prêt à partir
pour un nouveau et long voyage qui
arrive ya beaucoup d'autres enfants qui
nous attendent des enfants qui habitent
très loin mais nous reviendrons vite
vous voir c'est promis ansa c'est promis
promis je peux lui avait pas trop fait
vite nounours car nous avons encore une
très longue route à faire
et hop michel pop un peu plus haut moi
je suis pas content du tout qu'ils
partent en voyage pas moi non plus ou
pas ça drôle mais petit homme mes chers
petits amis mon cher petit dico lors des
chutes mais collet l'a pas content pour
redoux est-ce que vous partez de nouveau
en voyage fait pas tout seul c'est moi
si tu crois que c'est mal à tous ces
voyages nous reviendrons entrevue de
vous voir ce produit sinon par la plus
morieux feu sont dans mon grenier à
thème trop
tiens cartes sur la table on t'a fait
des surprises pour ton voyage des
comptes à manses de ce merveilleux coach
jaune c'est tous pour toi
les fleurs aussi
euh bof ce trou quelle belle droite
voilà moment
[Musique]
e
boucheron boulot moore était pleine ce
qui le choix ouais c'est moi qui l'ait
choisie pour toi et tu as vu notre
paquet mousse tout de suite c'est mon
cadeau à moi même pour le papillon ski
de choix classique elle vous est il un
miroir est un chic
j'ai l'impression que je fais très
gentil le mali
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
aucun boss i'm coming le cher petit il
faut que je soutiens annonce c'est pour
rien que je suis c'est la petite souris
oui cela lui donnera de notre part du
mandement jaune sable de nous chanter sa
belle chanson avant de partir bien sûr
but we look hors murs
[Musique]
obtient tout voyage merci des enfants
allons en route compagnon patron
chanteur votre chanson d'accord mon bon
nounours allez vous coucher sagement
chaque soir mes petits amis et nous
reviendrons bientôt je suis la marchande
stable la journée est finie il faut être
raisonnable
c'est le moment d'aller au lit tous les
jours sur mon nuage
nous nous revient avec moi et nous
partons en voyage dans le ciel par
dessus les toits
[Musique]
je n'ai pas d'autre bagages qu'un niveau
enchanté et du haut de mon nuage je
serai memon sable doré
voilà
bonsoir les enfants du monde
à demain
bonne nuit moi je continue ma ronde de
nuit à tous les jeudis au 9e nuit à tous
les petits
bordeaux 10
tout le petit
[Musique]